Perfecto.
E bueno, el concepto human the loop ya
lo habían escuchado antes.
Bueno, este es un concepto ya un poquito
viejito, viene de los 80s, más usado en
el en términos militares, pero hoy en
día adoptado por la Unión Europea debido
pues al al crecimiento de las
inteligencias artificiales y que algunas
son consideradas de alto riesgo. Pues
por eso se utiliza este término ahora en
tecnología. Y pues la gran pregunta que
todos se hacen es eh cómo creamos
inteligencia artificial que sea ética.
Para eso tenemos un invitado muy
especial el día de hoy que es el Dr.
Julio. E el doctor Julio trabaja en el
Ministerio de Tecnologías de la
Información y las Comunicaciones.
Perdón, don Julio,
eh específicamente eh lidera la Política
Nacional de Inteligencia Artificial en
Colombia en un marco estratégico de más
de 106 puntos. Además es mentor de
inteligencia artificial en el nodo de
EAFED y un firme impulsor del movimiento
EA for Good, eh promoviendo una
automatización que que amplifique las
capacidades humanas y no que las limite
o las reemplace. Entonces, por favor,
recibamos con un fuerte aplauso al señor
Julio.
Ahora sí, ahora me escuchan, ¿no? Hola,
hola, hola. Está como bajito, ¿no? Yo
creo que Hola. Ahora sí.
Bueno, bueno, buenas tardes, un gusto,
gracias por la invitación.
La verdad, yo soy de cero protocolos
porque es que es tanta burocracia y
tanta cosa como que hace que esto no
fluya bien y hay que tratar de articular
con las personas y con los humanos para
poder encontrar soluciones eh con
tecnología y potenciar el humano en el
centro. Y de eso vamos a hablar un poco
hoy, cómo eh explorar el tema de Human
in the seguramente algunos lo conocen,
algunos otros no. cómo se conecta esto
con Human Centric y cómo el tema de
sesgos algorítmicos éticos son
importantes a la hora de generar
proyectos de inteligencia artificial o
MVPs, que es lo clave. ¿Listo? Eh,
yo apoyo como PIAR en Ministerio de
Tecnologías de la Información, MinTIC,
desde hace un poco más allá de un año en
el evento Colombia 5.0. Ustedes lo han
escuchado por ahí, Colombia 5.0, 20, 30,
40, 50. El año pasado lleva 15 años este
evento haciéndose en Colombia y el año
pasado dijeron, "Ya no lo vamos a hacer
14 años en Bogotá, vamos a ir a los
territorios." y salimos a Cali,
Medellín, Cartagena, eh Guajira, Santa
Marta, el mismo formato, un poco más
pequeño, pero con el mismo misma
intensidad y el mismo cariño. O sea,
gente de Google, de Amazon, de de Cloud,
han hecho charlas como estas en sus
especialidades en esas ciudades para
ayudar a cerrar la brecha, zonas gamers,
eh experiencias para emprendimientos
para personas que están en el en el
sector y en la y en la línea de de de la
ciudad. Entonces, ha sido una
experiencia muy muy enriquecedora.
Claramente los queremos invitar a que
hagan parte de Colombia 5.0 en las
próximas versiones. Quedan tres bichada
siguiente semana, jueves y viernes.
Viajamos el miércoles a Bichada, a
Puerto Carreño, Casanare, julio, eh,
perdón, agosto y cerramos en Amazonas el
10 y 11 de septiembre. Amazonas creo que
va a ser una cosa espectacular lo que
vamos a hacer allá. Listo. Entonces, nos
fuimos.
Esto es una evolución.
Todos ya conocen el tema de
transformación digital. Muchos hablan de
que les cambian el apellido. Muchos
hablan de que al principio necesitamos
una página web, después necesitamos un
e-commerce, después necesitamos una unos
unas redes sociales y unos followers y
empezamos a generar comunidad sea con
nuestra marca personal o con la marca
que vamos a representar o que estamos
generando en el emprendimiento. Y llegó
pues la inteligencia artificial con chat
GPT. Esto ustedes ya saben hace cuánto,
2 tr años, pero esto ya existía hace
mucho tiempo. Pero entonces cuando salió
todo este boom de tecnologías emergentes
y de conceptos, la gente que está
diciendo, "Venga, ya vamos despacio."
Porque hay muchos cambios y no sé cómo
digerir esto, no sé cómo adoptarlo,
¿cierto?
Entonces se habla que ya empezamos a
generar toda la evolución del internet,
después llegó el teléfono, después llegó
como tal lo que les estaba comentando el
de del e-commerce. Ya se está hablando a
nivel de psicología que eh hay muchas
personas que están desarrollando esta
curvatura de acá por estar todo el
tiempo así y no vamos a estar como
erguidos para poder trabajar. Esto está
pasando por el uso del manejo del
celular. Es increíble. Y hay estudios de
eso y por eso el tema del Doom Scruling,
si han escuchado lo del tema de las
redes sociales, es una locura. O sea, en
Europa ya están prohibiendo las redes
sociales a menores de 15 años. Aquí se
están analizando cosas para poder
articular esto y que eso sea real,
porque ya se están inventando las Riban
eh Metaglass, las Glass con X marcas.
Ayer conocí las Rivan, una locura. Yo
decía, "Dios mío, esto para dónde va."
Es increíble. Pero claramente la gente
está adoptando la inteligencia
artificial o las tecnologías por moda o
porque alguien las compró y yo la quiero
comprar y porque soy cool y quiero ser
cool y eso es lo que no se debe hacer.
¿Listo?
¿Y por qué es importante todo esto?
Porque
hoy más que nunca hay una cantidad de
información y de data en el mundo que no
la podemos manejar, no somos capaces de
digerirla. No somos capaces de
identificarla, no somos capaces de
hacerle la trazabilidad del dato, de
analizarla, de capturarla, de
identificarla, de almacenarla.
Sí,
hoy todo genera datos y lo cuando estos
señores, que son los weaballs vayan a
generar eh información a través de la
del internet y las cosas, pues vamos a
duplicar o quintuplicar la información.
¿Quién tiene un smartwatch acá?
la mayoría.
¿Quién tiene una trazabilidad de sus
pasos y de sus y de sus eh palpitaciones
del corazón y sabe y ta ta ta? ¿Quién
hace un Excel semanalmente que diga
cuánto lleva y cuánto duermo y cuántas
horas y el BO2 máximo de y se mide en el
mes siguiente a ver si ha mejorado o
empeorado?
La misma lo tiene o hay gente que no lo
hace, pero para allá va la vaina, ¿sí me
entienden?
Entonces es un aquí hay un tema que
puede ser extremista, ¿no? O sea, pilas
con el tema de de de de de volvernos
locos por medir todo, porque al fin y al
cabo la gente va a decir, "No, es que si
no se mide, no, está bien." Vale,
entonces esto va evolucionando un tema
de deporte de salud. Bueno, ya ustedes
saben cómo funciona el tema de IoT para
no ir muy lejos. ¿Quién sabe qué es
esto?
¿Lo han visto por ahí? ¿Qué se imaginan
que sea eso?
Don Nicolay. Exactamente.
Esto es un plegamiento de proteínas
que están analizando con inteligencia
artificial para curar las enfermedades
del mundo. Y lo está haciendo los
señores de Alphafold, de Google, el
señor Demis Hasabis, si lo han
escuchado,
él montó una empresa que se llama
Didmine hace muchos años y empezó a
trabajar con esto, con IA. Y Google le
dijo, "Oiga, esa idea está muy buena.
Venga para acá y cree Google Didmind y
están plegando proteínas para currer las
enfermedades. En unos pocos años, Dios
mediante, vamos a tener la cura del
cáncer, de la diabetes, de todo esto.
Eso va a ser creíble. Y y eso, ¿qué va a
hacer? Pues que tengamos mejor calidad
de vida. ¿No se han dado cuenta que la
gente ahorita ya come mejor?
Ya muchos no están tomando.
¿Quién consume alcohol? De millenials
para arriba.
Pero la Z, les cuento, y la que está
abajo de la Z, que se me olvidó, ¿cuál
es? Ya no están consumiendo alcohol
y están comiendo mejor.
Sí,
ya todo el mundo hoy el boom en el
mundo, ¿cuál es? No tiene proteína. No,
no. Entonces, no la consumo porque yo
necesito proteína para mi cuerpo. Está
bien, pero si se han dado cuenta como
están cambiando los modelos
y eso hace parte de todo esto porque la
gente se está dando cuenta que puede
mejorar su calidad de vida alimentándose
mejor, haciendo ejercicio y ayudando con
la inteligencia artificial a mejorar las
capacidades del cuerpo humano.
¿Y por qué les hablo de todo esto?
Porque al fin y al cabo, cuando nosotros
entendamos y cambiemos el chip de querer
capacitarnos en skills, de querer hacer
ese open skilling, de querer generar
soluciones de inteligencia artificial
como la que estamos generando en una
jacatón como estas, pues vamos a poder
conectarnos primero las personas,
después los procesos, después las
empresas y después las ciudades.
Eso es un ejemplo de Smart City.
Vancouver Canadá
es un video real de Vancouver que nos
muestra el tema del tránsito, el tema de
cuántas personas están caminando por
diferentes espacios, la capacidad de
carga de turismo de diferentes espacios
turísticos, la capacidad de carga de los
estadios, todo eso que pasó. Si vieron
lo del mundial, una cosa loca, ¿no? Lo
que más me llamó la atención del mundial
es con el el matchum,
eso me parece un exitazo que decían como
por picos. la cantidad de veces que
llegaba el equipo al al área y quién
tenía más el balón y quién eso. Eso no
existía.
Eso para un técnico es una locura y para
un aficionado es una locura porque uno
dice, "Oiga, vea, estamos ganando el
partido, pero no hemos llegado sin una
sola vez." Todos esos son datos y al fin
y al cabo las ciudades se van a conectar
y hay ciudades en el mundo que ya son
ciudades inteligentes y por eso es
importante que ustedes desarrollen
soluciones
éticas responsables y sostenibles para
conectar estas ciudades desde el
software, desde las aplicaciones, desde
los MVPs, desde todo lo que se crea.
Mucho gusto, mi nombre es Julio César
Murcia.
Eh, por allá en la pandemia, cuando
todos nos estábamos viendo locos,
yo creí, oiga, yo empecé a trabajar en
diferentes empresas, en Telefónica, en
diferentes organizaciones, en la
Alcaldía de Bogotá, fui líder de
transformación digital de la alcaldía de
Bogotá, viajaba y me invitaban a charlas
y a llevar tecnología al territorio.
Estos son maletas STEM blindadas con
contenidos y tabletas STM para los
chicos en la Guajira. Y cuando yo fui
allá, yo dije, "Pucha, hay que
aterrizarle esto a la gente porque la
gente no tiene idea de lo que viene,
no tiene idea la cantidad de tsunami de
tecnologías emergentes que se vienen de
aquí en adelante. Entonces dije, voy a
crear un personaje que ayude a humanizar
y democratizar la tecnología para que a
través de la generación de contenido y
un podcast que tengo que se llama
cacharrear, los invito a que lo escuchen
por ahí en YouTube,
pues la gente entiende un poco esto,
para dónde va. Entonces, en acacharrear,
¿qué hacemos? Entrevisto a los líderes
de las grandes empresas multinacionales
del mundo. Voy poco a poco, no quiero
generar podcast cada 8 días como todo el
mundo, que hay que generar contenido
porque es que los views y a mí eso no me
interesa. O sea, yo necesito hacer
entrevistas de calidad para que la gente
se oriente y sepa para dónde va. He
montado cuatro entrevistas, una con
Oracle, él es el country manager de
Oracle, es argentino. Cuando tengan
tiempo la miran, dura media hora. Mis
podcast no duran más de 30 minutos
porque no quiero que la gente pierda
tanto tiempo, sino que se concentre y
pueda aprender cosas. Y es una charla,
una berraquera porque el man es
argentino y yo le pregunto cómo utilizar
el big data en la Fórmula 1
y cómo funciona el big data en la
Fórmula 1. Entonces, él me explica toda
la trazabilidad de los datos en la
Fórmula 1. Está muy bacano. Y por ahí
también entrevisté al de Amazon, Daniel
Saldarriaga, también nos cuenta todo el
tema de de lo que hace con Bedrock y
todo lo de WS y él me cuenta ahí en eso
y también con IBM. Estoy detrás de
Google y estoy detrás de eh Clot, pero
con Clot creo que me va a tocar viajar
Estados Unidos, pero va a ser
interesante esas conversaciones.
Entonces, bienvenidos. Ahí nos vemos
Julito Tic en Instagram o en YouTube y
en LinkedIn Julio César Murcia. Ay, a
veces hecho carreta por allá en Blue en
Blue 4.0.
Bueno, ¿qué vamos a hacer en estos? Yo
creo que media hora, no me voy a morir
mucho, dice 45, pero la idea es como
contarles algunas cosas puntuales de lo
que hemos identificado desde ministerio
y en mi experiencia en desarrollo de
proyectos.
Yo he trabajado un poco más allá de
12 a 15 jacatones desde el año pasado.
Entonces, ya más o menos sabemos cómo
esto funciona.
¿Qué es importante?
Vamos a ver por qué importa este
contexto, cómo son las validaciones
éticas, por qué es importante el
concepto de human y la sostenibilidad en
los MVPs, humanop, los sesgos y la
gobernanza de los datos.
Cuando usted construye rápido, hoy en
día todo el mundo está en el loop de
tengo que hacer, tengo que generar,
tengo, tengo, tengo, tengo. Y las
modelos de inteligencia artificial nos
están permitiendo a nosotros generar
MVPs en minutos o en horas que antes nos
tomaban días o meses. ¿Sí se han dado
cuenta?
Pero aquí está pasando algo clave y es
que las personas no tienen en cuenta o
los desarrolladores
no tienen en cuenta variables
importantes como humanoop. Entonces se
habla de tres conceptos claves. Ah, esta
no es es la siguiente, pero acá se
habla, por ejemplo, de tres niveles de
autonomía. Human in the loop o human en
el o humano en el bucle permite que
cuando tú haces un proceso cíclico o en
loop, el humano esté dentro del mismo
loop.
Antier estuvimos, ayer, ¿qué fue?
Antier, antier estuvimos en la en Platzi
con un evento de Cloud Meetup Bogotá, un
evento queú estuviste por ahí y
coincidieron en esto. O sea, esto es muy
clave. Claramente cuando los proyectos
demandan capacidades importantes de
recursos, tanto técnicos como
financieros, ¿cierto? Dependiendo del
tamaño del proyecto se hace más grande
el human in the loop. ¿De acuerdo? ¿Por
qué es importante esto? Porque hay que
definir estos cinco pasos. ¿Qué es lo
que está pasando? ¿Cómo genero el pron
engineering? ¿Dónde estoy acá como
checkpoint validando la información
dentro del loop del modelo de del de
software? ¿Cómo lo integro el MVP y cómo
genero un pitch? ¿Qué es lo que ustedes
van a hacer en la jacatón?
Voy a verlo un poco más gráfico.
Entonces, acá viene el input, ¿cierto?
Conecto a cualquiera. ¿Han hecho el
estudio más o menos quién está
trabajando? O esto está abierto a
cualquier LM acá hoy
está abierto. Se va trabajar cloud,
Gemini,
cualquiera. Ah, buenísimo. Listo.
Entonces, piensen en el que estén
trabajando ahorita, ¿cierto?
Tools,
las que sean, las que quieran. CQL,
Gemini, Workspace, Hogin Face, GitHub,
etcétera.
Y aquí está el HITL, Human in the Loop,
que es la validación que yo tengo que
hacerle al modelo del loop para poder
validear que eso sí me va a generar una
respuesta positiva y me está generando
lo que yo le estoy indicando desde el
input.
Entonces ahí yo genero esto, genero mi
observación, le digo, "Oiga, venga, no
se oye tanto la cabeza, váyase por este
lado, consulte estos datos, pilas con
estos datos éticos, pilas con estas
fuentes, porque usted me está jalando
información de donde no es y yo quiero
que se vaya por acá y no por acá,
¿cierto? Y ahí sí me genera la respuesta
final en el output.
Aquí hay digamos que tres conceptos
importantes. Eh, uno es el human
incomon, que es el humano decide la la
sugiere o genera borradores. Uno, el
otro es in the loop, que es el que
acabamos de ver y el otro es human.
Sí, que es cuando la opera de manera un
poco más autónoma, no está como digamos
ya le dio el el loop el humano y la
validación técnica y la IA puede tener
más capacidad de decisión.
Pero aquí entra una cosa importante que
lo vamos a ver al final de la charla y
es el tema de la capacidad del humano de
la criticidad para desarrollar un
pensamiento crítico sobre la solución.
Ojo con eso, porque lo que está pasando
en los jacatones y lo que está pasando
hoy en día con el boom de la es, ¿qué
estamos haciendo? Móntelo, copy paste,
tan, play, dele play, cha y chao.
Y resulta que hay un concepto que se
llama cognitive of loveling o descarga
cognitiva, que ya lo vamos a ver
ahorita, y resume
que estamos descargando cognitivamente
el cerebro en la inteligencia
artificial.
Por eso el humanop es tan importante,
porque en la medida que tú hagas un copy
paste sin el human in the loop o sin el
human centric, sin esas validaciones
éticas, tu porcentaje de pensamiento
crítico disminuye automáticamente. Hay
estudios sobre eso.
Por eso es importante tener en cuenta
algunas validaciones éticas para LLMs.
¿De dónde vienen los datos? Uno, ¿de
dónde salió ese dataset? ¿Cómo se lo
diste al LM? ¿Tienes permiso o no? ¿Es
open data, está cerrada? ¿Te la
permitieron? Etcétera. Dos,
explicabilidad mínima. ¿Por qué puedes
explicar una fase el modelo y por qué
generó ese output? Tres, ¿eso genera un
impacto real en las personas o no? ¿O lo
estás creando por crearlo?
¿Quién se beneficia? ¿Quién se perjudica
de lo que tú estás haciendo?
Cuatro. Verificación de alucinaciones,
las cajas negras, contraste, cifras,
nombres, cifras generadas, fuente real.
Y por último, ¿eso es reversible o no es
reversible? O ya se fue así y es MVP y
ya quedó montado y eso ya no hay forma y
eso no, mejor dicho,
existe un camino para esa decisión
automatizada, hay un sesgo sobre eso o
no.
Y aquí vienen dos conceptos claves que
seguramente algunos de ustedes los han
escuchado, pero es clave aclararlos y es
la deudotécnica
y el overfeiting.
Entonces la deuda técnica tiene que ver
con ese costo oculto de tomar decisiones
rápidas con la inteligencia artificial.
Entonces ustedes generan un proyecto y
el project manager dice, "No, eso lo
sacamos en un mes o en dos meses."
Y la deuda técnica es, "No, tenemos que
sacarlo un dos días porque hay que
hacerlo ya y hay que montarlo."
Pilas con eso porque hay muchos
proyectos que se están yendo y tienen un
porcentaje de deuda técnica muy alto por
esa decisión.
En la Jacatón, quizás tú mismo la
redonda escalamiento pagará después
pilas con el tema del código generado
por IA, sin testear, sin documentación,
sin compiar y sin entender lo que
estamos haciendo. Y el overfeing tiene
que ver con todo el tema cuando un
modelo o el MVP memoriza los datos de un
demo, por ejemplo, y no de un
entrenamiento completo de un MVP en un
modelo de desarrollo software.
Muchos caen en ese overfeiting
porque al final lo entrenan en un en un
demo que queda montado y lo presentan
así en una jacatón. Nos pasó en Santa
Marta la semana, hace como un mes.
Listo, muchachos. ¿Y eso dónde está?
Muéstreme las respuestas y muéstrenme
dónde está conectado eso y muéstreme en
tiempo real eso. Ay, no, es que es un
demo. Perdió.
Eso es muy importante, sobre todo en un
tema de jacatones, porque esto lo que se
busca es escalabilidad.
Eh, también se habla un poco del LLM
real time, que es como la actualización
de todo el tema de las APIs, cómo hago
la búsquida, el tema del RAC, cómo
integro la información real de, en este
caso RAC es clave para col subsidio.
Ustedes están acá para solucionar
problemas de col subsidio en crédito, en
vivienda, en en vehículos, etcétera, y
están solucionando problemas reales de
col subsidio. Eso es muy importante.
Dos, el lo prom engineering, que fue lo
que acabamos de ver del ciclo de
retroalimentación, lo que vimos el human
in the los ajustes correspondientes.
Eh, otros conceptos importantes son los
famosos skills, ya no se habla tanto de
prom engineering, sino los skills que
son como entreno yo para poder tener
varios skills y poder reciclar skills y
utilizarlos en otros MVPs. Eso funciona
muy bien. Por eso hay tantos skills
montados en GitHub. Eh, quiero montar un
skills para temas de plegamiento de
proteínas para curar el cáncer. Ah, ya
lo tengo. Entonces, lo jalanen de allá.
Muchos de ustedes, me imagino, que
tienen un tema en en GitHub y lo tienen
en Substack. Substack es una buena red
que está cogiendo mucha fuerza. Linding,
claramente es importante. A veces hace
mucho hype Linding por todo y todo,
porque ustedes saben que Linding es como
he hecho yo soy, yo tengo la solución.
Cambio en Sofsack ya es más como de
colaboración. tengan enstack. Es muy
interesante lo que está pasando en
Sofstac. ¿Y por qué es importante todo
esto? Porque vamos para allá
en Boriet AI oía encarnada.
¿Qué está pasando? Que las soluciones
que estamos desarrollando hoy acá para
procesos empresariales como Col
Subsidio,
si yo después puedo generar un equipo
agéntico en software, perfecto.
¿Cierto?
Pero si yo después quiero que ese agente
tome vida y haya un humanoide haciendo
lo que hace la gente virtual, pero
caminando de forma física y se la pase
por el subsidio, eso va a pasar.
Ayer conocí a alguien super chévere en
que viene de Medellín que eh
está desarrollando un software para
AI, un robot que él creó.
Los humanoides hoy en día no son
autónomos,
son teleoperados. Todos les venden el
control remoto y todo esto. Ya lo vamos
a ver.
¿Por qué? Porque esto puede cambiar
vidas, industrias. Acá están un poco el
tema de los de los humanoides, robot
social. Se habla mucho de la robótica
social implementada para, por ejemplo,
temas con los la tercera edad, con los
niños, con las personas de discapacidad,
manufactura,
salud y smart warehouse, etcétera.
Un poco de cifras. Eh, el AI Index
Report de la Universidad Stanford, que
es uno de los índices más grandes de
inteligencia artificial del mundo, el
año pasado, dijo, "Vean la cantidad de
proyección de robots que vienen en el
mundo y cómo se están generando
actualmente y en qué industrias.
Transporte y logística. Años 21, 22, 23,
24. Colores,
profesionales de limpieza, medicina,
hospitalidad y agricultura.
Acá es donde se están generando mayor
cantidad de robots,
llámese humanoides o industriales para
estas industrias. Vean el potencial que
tiene esto cuando esto lleggaue a la
educación, cuando esto llega a las
empresas.
Esto es un ejemplo más o menos de cómo
generan un modelo escalable de training
en en humanoides,
los sensores y todo esto que tienen los
servos y bueno, las las capacidades.
Pero lo que voy con esto es las
actualmente eh seguramente algunas las
han escuchado, lo han visto, todo esto
está operado a través de cámaras en
India y en China y en diferentes
sectores. En Vietnam hay personas que
están hay escuelas en China hay escuelas
de robots para que las personas a través
de exoesqueletos eh puedan generar los
movimientos de un robot y sean más
naturales.
Entonces, vea esto cómo está avanzando
eh de rápido. ¿Qué podemos hablar de
temas de sesgos? Digamos que cuatro
cuatro sesgos puntuales que pueden
pasar. Uno, sesgos de datos, lo que
estamos hablando al comienzo, dataset de
entrenamiento que le diste al LM.
Ojo con eso. Dos, sesgo de confirmación.
El equipo acepta la primera respuesta
del modelo, pero coincide con lo que yo
esperaba sin contrastarla. Eso es
importantísimo.
Tres, sesgo interacción. Aprende cómo
usan los primeros usuarios y amplifica
ese patrón y sesgo de automatización.
El equipo confía más de lo que eh arrojó
la IA sin necesidad de hacer la
verificación y sin ser crítico en el
desarrollo de la solución.
¿Cómo mitigar esto en una jacatón de 48
horas en las que ustedes están? ¿Cuándo
empezaron? ¿Ayer o antier? Antier, ¿no?
Virtual o virtual o presencial hoy.
Presencial hoy y mañana.
Ah, el domingo también.
¿Hasta qué horas hoy?
7 y mañana también. 8 a 7.
Virgen santa.
Están dando comiditas y bien tratados.
cafecito.
¿Cómo mitigar estos sesgos? Diversifica
la muestra de prueba. Prueba tu MVP en
diferentes perfiles y distintos de
grupos de edad etéreos, hombre, mujer,
rangos de edad. Siempre identifiquen a
esto, para quién va, ¿no? El producto
que están generando es cuál es el
público objetivo de esto y quién, cómo y
cómo lo y lo testean. Dos, audit el
prom, no solo el output, lo que hablamos
al comienzo de human para evitar
sesgados al sesgos al modelo. Una mirada
humana, alguien que dentro del equipo,
¿cuántos son? ¿Tres personas o cuatro?
Cinco. Hay tres, cinco, cuatro. Alguien
que de afuera no esté tan sesgado y no
sea tan técnico que diga, "Venga, yo
quiero mirar eso desde el comienzo.
Experiencia de usuario. ¿Qué está
haciendo para experiencia de usuario?"
La experiencia uso es clave
porque a veces ustedes lo entienden.
Uex, correcto, a veces ustedes lo
entienden porque son técnicos, va
perfecto, pero alguien lo va a probar x
el vigilante. Esto, ¿cómo función? Yo no
entiendo aquí esto, este botón para qué
será. Todo tiene que ser
supercaro para las personas y documenta
las limitaciones correspondientemente.
Eh, aquí viene otro concepto importante
que es human. Aí, muy similar lo de
Human in the, pero acaba más pensando en
que las soluciones que estamos creando
tienen que ser pensadas para personas
como nosotros, para humanos, ¿sí?
Centradas en que le solucionen, en que
le mejore la calidad de vida, en que eso
funcione para algo. No todo tiene que
ser claramente para optimizar recursos
financieros, está bien, pero optimizar
recurso humano también va a ser
importante el tema human centric.
Y acá es cuando viene este concepto de
human que es la centrada en el ser
humano. Si han visto ese
ese cuadro, ese cuadro me encanta, es
como de botero, ¿no? Transmite como
soberanía digital, como ciudadanía, como
empatía digital, como todo lo que está
pasando ahorita, ¿cierto?
Entonces, ¿de qué forma volvemos un
enfoque de diseño y desarrollo
tecnológico centrado en el mejoramiento
de las capacidades de los humanos? Para
que la persona que desarrolla este tipo
de productos y las testea
piense, "Oiga, eso está pensado para
desarrollar mis capacidades y no para
reemplazarlas." Y con eso se acaba el
mito de todo el mundo, que la IA nos va
a quitar los trabajos y que sí,
esa fue una imagen que hice con Gemini.
Es para entender un poco con el tema de
la transparencia ética y cómo hacemos
esa relación humano IA para ese
equilibrio emocional, la empatía, el
juicio crítico y todo lo que eh eso pues
estamos conversando hoy.
Y hay otro concepto importante que tiene
que ver con sostenibilidad. Entonces,
¿de qué forma
yo escalo esto en el tiempo? O sea, que
esto se quede, que esto funcione. Sí.
Por eso esta jacatón es tan importante,
porque esta jacatón sí va a generar uno
premios para los que ganen y dos
escalabilidad de la solución porque se
va a quedar en col subsidio
y eso es muy positivo
y es muy berraco y muy difícil de
conseguirlo en otro tipo de jacatones
porque a veces salen o MVPs o startups o
productos que si no hay inversionistas
pues la gente no sigue adelante como hay
otras que sí.
Los ganadores de la Acatón de Colombia
5.0 el año pasado fueron de Medellín.
Están creando una empresa de agentes de
ciberseguridad. Están creando unos como
unos antihackers de ciber pero de IA. Y
me mostraron como 200 agentes trabajando
al mismo tiempo y ellos ya están
pensando en generar esa empresa, ya la
crearon en Medellín. Entonces, vean lo
la el potencialidad que puede haber
alrededor de todo esto. Entonces, pilas
con el, por ejemplo, para generar un
tema MVP sostenible, el código revisado
claramente, documentación de la otra
persona, el costo de los APIs, la
infraestructura,
el costo y optimización de tokens. En
esto es muy importante, sobre todo
cuando utilizamos el LLMs. Sí.
¿De qué forma optimizamos esto para
reducir el costo de los tokens?
El tema de la carga de la información.
Ustedes sabían que ya es más fácil
cargarle, no es que más difícil, perdón,
cargarle documentos en PDF a los LLMs
porque te consumen más tokens, sino que
ya hay otras herramientas para que eso
funcione de otra forma. Eso es clave.
Y a nivel de gobernanza de datos, pues
hay pilares importantes que pueden ser
primero, ¿de dónde viene y de dónde
proviene la información y si le están
dando permiso para eso. Uno, claramente
el subsidio está, me imagino que muy
claro en eso y si tuvieran que haberle
dicho eso, usted tiene los datas para
poderlo hacer. Dos, calidad y
trazabilidad de la información. ¿Puedes
rastrear la respuesta hasta qué dato?
Hasta el dato que la originó.
Eso es clave.
esa información que te da, tú la puedes
te puedes devolver y buscar hasta dónde
llegó el dato, de dónde salió esa
respuesta. Tres, privacidad y
minimización. ¿Estás usando solo el dato
o lo estás usando como un caso de uso
específico? Y cuatro, seguridad y
acceso. ¿Qué equipo, quién el equipo
puede ver o editar o exportar los datos
sensibles
con los que estamos trabajando? Para
esto hay muchos marcos, seguramente
algunos los conocen, otros no. Los
traigo como para que los los conozcan y
los vean. La OCD tiene unos principios
de IA y de transparencia de rendición de
cuentas para sistemas de IA. La UNESCO
tiene un marco de recomendación de uso
ético de la inteligencia artificial.
pensando un poco en esa supervisión
humana que hablamos, está el NIS DII,
que es un marco de riesgo de IA, y eh
está el tema del COMPESEX, Ministerio
TIC tiene un COMPES que es el 414
y está trabajando un modelo de política
de inteligencia artificial hoy para
poder ayudar a regular esto ética
responsable y sosteniblemente para tener
la hoja de ruta. Sí.
Eh, seguramente se aprobará y se
validará en el siguiente gobierno porque
esto es despertos, o sea, esto tiene que
estar gente que sepa del tema. Aquí no
tiene que estar, por ejemplo, que vamos
a hacer copy paste de la ley de
inteligencia artificial de la Unión
Europea. Nos podemos basar, está
perfecto, pero somos países
idiosincrasis y culturas diferentes. Por
eso acá tiene que haber y va a existir
una mesa de expertos de IA de Academia
Empresa Estado para poder rayar esto y
decir Colombia tiene que meterse por
este lado. Listo. y estamos trabajando
en eso eh en este momento. Ya digamos
que un poco para finalizar lo que les
hablaba el tema de Cognicive of un
concepto muy importante que es la
descarga cognitiva que estamos haciendo
con los LLMs o todo el tema de
inteligencia artificial que le estoy
delegando a nuestra a la LLM para que
nos desarrolle ese pensamiento.
Por eso les decía, el tema del
pensamiento crítico es clave
y aquí hay algunas variables o skills
importantes para desarrollar ese
pensamiento crítico.
Para poder tener un razonamiento
analítico, uno, para detectar los
sesgos, dos, para considerar las razones
éticas dentro del MVP, la adaptabilidad
y para solucionar problemas.
Hay un señor que se llama Daniel
Caneman, que es psicólogo,
que ese man es un teso teso de los
tesos. El man dijo pilas con el
desarrollo del pensamiento crítico para
que usted no pierda ese desarrollo del
pensamiento crítico.
Generó dos sistemas o él dice, "El
cerebro tiene dos sistemas de
pensamiento. Sistema de pensamiento uno
y sistema de pensamiento dos. Este es
más rápido, más peligroso y este es más
deliberativo y más de cheque y más de
evaluación lógica, de sesgos, de
exageraciones y de alucinaciones hacia
donde deberíamos ir siempre, no
solamente en las decisiones humanas que
tomemos nosotros, sino en el desarrollo
de proyectos y MVPs como este que
estamos haciendo acá. ¿Por qué? Porque
nosotros como humanos normalmente
siempre desarrollamos acá y decimos,
"No, solucionemos ya. Okay, listo. No,
eso está che, está perfecto y siempre
tomamos decisiones rápidas y hoy en día
esa hiperconectividad
e hiperinfoxicación en la que estamos
nos hace llevar a pensar de que la vida
va así. Y este señor dice, "Oiga, venga,
pare y hágale espacio."
Esto va a tener mucho sentido de aquí
para arriba. El que desarrolle esta
skill de desarrolle pensamiento del
sistema dos deliberativo y crítico más
las soft skills, que ya sabemos cuáles
son con las heart porque las heart las
va la va como a suplir, va a generar una
capacidad increíble de relacionamiento,
de trabajos, de proyectos,
etcétera.
Y por último, digamos que estas
preguntas es como para que ustedes
tengan en cuenta las validaciones éticas
que pueden tener de su MVP.
Trazabilidad.
¿Puedes explicar por qué o no? Lo que
imos un poco anteriormente, la
verificación técnica. Revisaste el
código, las vulnerabilidades,
consentimiento y licencias. Tenemos
derechos, doctor, privacidad, tenemos
los tokens como tal legados y los
tenemos eh autentificados. Transparencia
y reversibilidad tiene un poco que ver
con lo que vimos anteriormente.
Y al final, ay, pucha,
digamos que este es un checklist que
usted lo tienen que tener claro antes
del pitch. ¿Cuándo es el pit? ¿El sábado
o el domingo?
El domingo.
Entre hoy y mañana. Piénsense en esto.
Uno, hay al menos un checkpoint humano
documentando el flujo del NDP.
Humano,
no automático, automatizado. ¿Alguien
del equipo está verificando esto? ¿Cómo
ABC? ¿Cómo está el ciclo? ¿Cómo está el
loop? Experiencia de usuario. Prueba
dos. ¿Probaste el MVP con datos o
perfiles distintos a todos los del
equipo?
Importante. Tres. ¿Puedes explicar en
una frase de dónde salió cada dato
clave? Eso se lo van a preguntar los los
los
jurados.
Cuatro. Declaraste en el pitch las
limitaciones y sesgos conocidos.
Eso es ganador.
Ustedes pueden decir, esto puede pasar,
noamos esta solución, pero si eso no se
audita, si eso no se mide, si eso no se
traza, si eso no se le hace un
seguimiento en analítica y si no hay una
persona que haga ese seguimiento en ese
producto, puede fracasar por esto.
Y eso es un en vez de ser una cosa
negativa, puede ser positiva para
ustedes porque están metiéndole el tema
de la gobernanza de datos y la
gobernanza de IA y la ética en un modelo
de MVP. Y por último, ¿existe un plan
mínimo de mantenimiento si el MVP gana o
continúa? Claramente aquí sí, ¿no? Por
el tema el subsidio, pero está bien
preguntárselo.
Señores, señoritas,
por más de que la IA construya rápido,
el Human in the construye confianza.
Nunca se les olvide eso.
Nos vemos en redes. Muchas gracias. Lo
que necesiten, un placer. Acá estoy en
Linding y nos vemos por ahí. Voy a estar
dando vueltas hoy acá. Muchas gracias,
muchachos, muy amables. Que les pase muy
bien. Que gane el mejor.
Bueno, muchas gracias.
E
en un momento ya vamos a comenzar con
otra charla.